Salut la Team Mentalo !
Ça fait quelques semaines que je vous avais demandé sur Facebook
de m'envoyer tous vos mind Map pour en faire une vidéo
quelques semaines, donc j'ai eu du retard !
dont l'organisation de mon meet-up qui se passe cet après-midi au YouTube Space
et là je me suis dit: avant le meet-up, tu fais la vidéo.
**générique**
donc j'ai reçu pleins de Mind Maps différents
tous intéressants
il y en a qu'étaient complètement barrés et d'autres très utiles
j'en ai selectionné une petite quinzaine et on va les regarder ensemble
ils sont rangés par ordre alphabétique
donc je les ouvre au hasard, il y a celui de Bren Lefloch
donc c'est les pseudos facebook
j'ai trouvé très intéressant celui-ci parce qu'on a bien
l'élément central de départ
on peut identifier facilement les 7 flèches
je pense que je les aurai mises en valeur avec des couleurs différentes
et c'est très synthétique, c'est tout à fait le but
et surtout on a des éléments clés autour
et c'est ça dont va se rappeler le cerveau
Celui de Carolina aussi est intéressant
parce que celui de Carolina elle s'en sert, elle l'a mis dans le message
Facebook, comme d'une espace de trame à suivre
pour pouvoir en un seul coup d'œil savoir où elle est en
et voir une arborescence
dans un fil conducteur
d'entretien de coaching. Et c'est vrai que j'avais
pas trop parlé de cette option-là
mais on peut s'en servir également pour se
faire des fils conducteurs
de rendez-vous, de conversation
de discours
pour le coup, là un discours de A à B ça n'a aucun intérêt par contre si on veut un discours vivant
mais sans oublier des points clés à aborder
Ça c'est très bien
Celui de Caroline je l'avais sélectionné aussi parce que
voilà on sait que c'est pas un
intérêt de choses à retenir
c'est juste un truc de synthèse qu'elle s'est fait,
n'empêche que, très visuellement, en quelques secondes, on sait ce qu'elle aime
Un de mes préférés c'est celui de Charlotte
alors même si effectivement
c'est pas forcément le plus créatif
le plus coloré, il est parfait
Il est parfait parce qu'on a le Spleen au milieu
et après on retrouve les éléments clés dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure
la saleté où elle a sali la feuille
la mort avec la tête de mort
la maladie avec la pharmacie
le temps qui passe directement le sablier
et ça, pour synthétiser les informations
et se faire une fiche de travail, c'est juste parfait
Celui de Lucas varo
là on était plus sur un esprit Pierre Crocien
Pourquoi j'ai fait ce Mind Map?
Ben - parce que je savais pas quoi faire
- parce que je m'ennuie en cours de français
ouais ben d'ailleurs suit un petit peu parce que tu verras qu'il y a 2-3 trucs à corriger *rires*
- parce que je suis au dernier rang et que la prof ne me voit pas
Ah oui juste à côté il y a Ludivine
qui s'était déchiré c'est un mind
map spécial
*roulements du tambour*
koh-lanta.
ça c'est du
très bon mind map allez à la limite, le seul truc:
mettre un peu plus en valeur les
mots quand même
si c'est quelque chose qu'on  doit apprendre ou retenir
mais c'est très très clair.
Bon, pour info, elle en avait aussi envoyé un
un deuxième sur les sources de la
croissance économique je suis pas sûr
qu'ils vous amusent autant .
Machan: alors, là je vous laisse le regarder et vous devez deviner ce que c'est et à quoi ça sert
donc on a un "zoo" au milieu
tout autour, on a des animaux qui font une
action précise. A quoi peut servir ce mind map?
il sert à des élèves de maternelle
Leurs enseignants  et les enfants de maternelle
ont décidé ensemble de
ce qu'il ne fallait pas faire
dans une classe. En rappel ils se sont
faits un espèce de mind map comme ça
pour enfants
quand je vous disais qu'il ait pas
d'âge pour utiliser ça
On est dans l'exemple concret
on a reçu de la part de manon de la fameuse répliquation
procaryote
qui va sauver le monde dans
quelques années, on suppose en tout cas
tout est là et vous pouvez dire
j'y étais je l'ai vu.
Raïchuchu
j'espère que je prononce bien
Raïchuchu sur toutes les étapes
ou du moins tout ce qui est à définir pour
écrire un roman fantastique
ça aussi c'est une bonne utilisation du
Mind Map pour avoir une vision globale de
ce qu'on a à faire
et en même temps c'est un espèce de
brainstorming puisque tout en
faisant le mind map on va identifier
les choses à faire elles sont pas
forcément un ordre précis c'est ça
qui est essentiel
on peut pas dire qu'il faut tout de
suite penser aux personnages
ou alors d'abord aux lieux
c'est un mélange de tout ça en fait
d'écrire un roman donc le mind map est très
adapté tout ça. Sarah boudreau un
petit mind map que j'affectionne parce que
oui, je suis très geek alors forcément
ça me plaît moi de voir ça du et, du ou
de tous les systèmes
logiques celui-ci ces sixteen
celui-ci c'est sixteen ce qui ne s'est
pas facile à dire
celle-ci c'est donc *rires*
non je n'arriverai pas à le redire deux fois
celui-ci s'est sixteen qui l'a envoyé
on ne voit pas très bien, malheureusement.
ça aussi c'est une très
bonne utilisation du mind map parce que
c'est la synthèse de tout le poème
qu'elle a appris par coeur de
Lewis carole et juste en suivant les dessins
à partir du 1
comme ça et en tournant elle va être
capable de se rappeler des éléments et
donc des phrases à prononcer et c'est
très très très très malin d'avoir
fait ça.
Vicky qui nous a fait un super mind map sur le vegan
Et qui nous a fait du speed painting à la fin
Ca pourrait persque être une
synthèse de conférence
alors en améliorant ou en changeant deux-trois trucs
mais pour défendre le projet
vegan, c'est super. Elle en avait
envoyé un autre beaucoup plus chelou
me concernant. toujours dans les styles j'ai un projet
je cherche à le définir et celui de violette
alors bien sûr un trip sur vivre sur
mars
mais là aussi une mine de rien
pour faire la vanne de faire le
mind map de vivre sur mars on voit tout
à fait brain storming qui
c'est mis en place
il y a déjà une arborescence et déjà
quelque chose de très logique donc on
est plus sur une carte euristique
que sur un mind map la différence
c'est les couleurs, c'est dans la
construction
mais c'est très utile quand même la
preuve celui de Clément Morin est aussi
intéressant dans une autre utilisation
il s'en est servi pour voir les
avantages les inconvénients des quatre
futurs qui se dessinent pour lui et qu'il
voudrait choisir. Tu voit ça Clément,
c'est quelque chose que j'ai jamais
pensé à faire l'utiliser le mind map
pour faire une prise de décision avec
les inconvénients et avantages dont je
vais clairement te voler l'idée pour
l'appliquer moi-même à mes prise de
décision certaine parce qu'au final
c'est très clair. merci beaucoup de me
les avoir renvoyés, d'avoir joué le jeu.
Ca m'a permis (alors j'ai pas pu toutes les
passer évidemment) mais de faire
voir à tout le monde un panel de ce
qu'on pouvait faire via le mind map et les
cartes euristiques j'ai été ravi
déjà de voir que vous vous serviez de
cet outil-là maintenant depuis que vous
l'ai fait découvrir. ça fait toujours
tellement plaisir. Et grâce à vous et
tout ce que vous m'avez envoyé ça m'a
permis dans cette vidéo de faire voir
aux autres toutes les formes
d'utilisation possible et que ça
sert à rien d'être grands dessinateurs:
Il y en a qui dessinaient très bien il y en a qui dessinaient pas du tout
c'est pas gênant
ça n'empêche pas de le faire
et d'utiliser ça. Merci beaucoup en tout
cas d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous aura plu et on
continuera à faire d'autres vidéos ensemble là, j'ai refait
des true stories
et on a refait des vidéos ensemble
j'ai refait une vidéo avec Akinator
je pense que la prochaine étape
c'est donc la vidéo où je vous
mentalise l'un d'entre vous ou l'une d'entre vous par skype
je vous tiens au courant de ça si cette
vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez le faire
savoir pas la peine de faire un mind map,
je suis sûr que cette image mentale
vous parle vous pouvez également vous
abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
moi je file à mon meet up cet après-midi
je vous raconterai ça sur la chaîne bien sûr
Je ne vous le dis pas souvent mais
pensez à partager cette vidéo ou des
vidéos comme ça sur la mémoire ou quoi
Ça ça peut être vraiment utile  à d'autres
personnes donc autant en profiter et je
vous dis rendez-vous demain à 17 heures
tchao